all right let's go to Mike Mike here's
your chance to get on the board okay
what does ta stand for in the challenger
series trans Automotive can we accept
that John yes we'll accept that answer
all right the or Trans Am would have
been acceptable we have a point its
track attack well ta says here ta stands
for trans not not on a challenger it
doesn't and he said trans auto mode what
do you say a track attack gentlemen is
Ronnie's challenging he's challenging
your answer Ronnie I'm sorry but the
challenger it stands for Trans Am it's a
it's a tribute to the Trans Am no it's
not did not allow you use the word
transia mon their car yes that's why
it's but it's the definition is not
Trans Am you're arguing with the judge
yes I am I'm sorry Ronnie my results are
final okay saying you say on the wrong
car then no you own a challenger Trans
Am no Antoinette's route challenge a TA
and what is the TA station raccattack
you're wrong okay I'm wrong all right
Mike you up one point Ronnie has zero
but now is Ronnie's burner okay Ronnie I
interrupt you we have multiple sources
here that says Trans Am and actually
when you type in a track attack Hot
Wheels comes up oh so it's little little
Cara OH Ronnie's toy car Rack Attack